um okay we gotta talk about drake now  you know you're a big fan of drake's um  you guys like need some meet and get a  selfie yeah i know right that would be  awesome this hasn't happened yet no no i  just got back to toronto yesterday so  you know okay so are you and he's on  tour  but are you guys working are your people  working on setting something up it'd be  really awesome if i met drake like i  don't know what i'd do  i'd probably be like trying to keep my  cool but  how close would meeting drake come to  winning olympic gold i don't know i  can't say  they're not really in the same  category of happiness i guess i don't  know how to explain it just because  olympic gold is like completely  different from anything else but yeah  something you work at your whole life